so it's like nah I feel like we should
get rid of freedom for women I know I
feel like I feel like
I feel like the vote we couldn't wait
then if we if we're oh bring me freedom
for women we're let's remove options
there's too many options these days as
well everyone thinks that everyone is
replaceable like before you said every
you make your bed you lie in there yeah
that's your thing you take it you pick
till you choose it you take it go but
that's values though
okay what would happen if divorce was
illegal divorce is my legal it's having
a 50 sale what would happen What would
happen if divorce was illegal
you make better choices what would
happen if you were legally married to
anyone you had a child with oh wait say
that again what would happen you
wouldn't married to anyone you had a
child
and divorce was illegal yeah you would
you would make better choices I already
believe in the main marriages you do I
believe in the old-fashioned marriages
where the cultures I don't care what
culture it is where you get the the
mummies and the daddies and the aunties
and they come together and and a lot of
people I've got a lot of engine I
couldn't in my children
some of them are having love marriages
some of them had the range marriages and
a lot of people think the main marriage
is like
that's the man that's you you're gonna
go together but there's a lot of work
that goes into it and I've seen it in
Africa and I've seen it my African
friends as well where they all get
together and they decide you know what
if this is the man you like let's check
out his family let's check out his
background let's come together and talk
and the weird thing is I was in Barbados
and my nephew
was having a baby with a girl
and my sister my late sister was oh I'm
going to meet the family I'm like what
do you mean oh well he's having a baby
we need to go meet the family my first
view was saying in a minute they never
called you when they were having sex how
come now they're pregnant you're gonna
go meet the family but apparently it was
their thing that you got my daughter
pregnant or my daughter allows you to
get her pregnant and all the family they
come together and they sit down and they
discuss what's gonna happen and I'm
talking not like 50 years ago I'm
talking this is happening like five ten
years ago and it still goes on in
certain societies where you get pregnant
or you get together we're gonna get
together and talk and I think there
needs to be a village
that that Village needs to be there that
Village and that's what's missing
because everybody's doing their own
thing and saying that this is right and
that is not wrong but if they have their
Old Village together to get together and
help them make decisions
because I even know like um I had
African people and when they were having
a problem in their relationships before
all this social media I'm like where you
go oh I'm going to see my uncle I have
to speak to them
I have to go I don't know what do you
mean or if the girl gets pregnant where
are you going I'm going my mother is
coming I'm I'm having a baby I'm like
what do you mean nope it's tradition you
go and you take either the mother come
off it was weird but it works out and I
understand it now I had African friends
and when they have a baby
yeah for three months at least you see
what I mean and and that was fantastic
because she was show her how to cope how
to cook you can do all of this and all
of that while she's having the children
the mother-in-law and she helps and
teaches her while she's having a baby
and nowadays it's like I'm gonna have a
baby and I'm gonna have this where your
parents where is that and I'm not
talking about years ago because I saw
this happening like 20 years ago yeah
and it works ultimately to me it works
especially with the African societies
but now you get these new modern African
people and they don't want to go to
their Elders it'd be great if you've got
a problem rather than go on social media
and talk about it go to your elders that
is what is that is what is good about
some of the tradition is that they're
there for your backup and I'm so used to
like my African friends going and
talking to their Elders or I used to
find it really weird like you and your
husband having problems and you're
having this meeting you go in the house
it's like the whole room is full of all
these old people and you're sitting down
there discussing your problems and it
works because the ultimate Foundation of
society's family and family them family
structures are lacking these days
unfortunately because me as well till
today there's a problem my dad would be
like I'm calling yeah like and I'm like
oh God but because Society has now made
us very self-absorbed my feelings my
feelings my feelings we don't want other
people to in you know intrude and the
thing is because you know that all your
whole family is getting involved don't
that change your behavior absolutely
thank you so there's certain things that
you won't do or there's certain things
you want to let them know about you
can't you can't bring like the the come
up like rapper back to your dad and say
oh no no my only straight up if you're
coming into my house anybody who meets
my dad to be ready to marry me no that's
what I'm saying like because girls will
go for like the bad guys
but I'm saying I'm saying like that
wouldn't that wouldn't happen you know
so I just used Like Rappers yeah yeah
but for me some some of them are good
and juicy sorry years ago when you took
your but say like if you went and you
said oh this is my partner hmm
what are your intentions towards my
daughter yes can I see your bank account
which is your job what are you and all
of that yeah and I remember going to
like weddings where I always thought it
was Indian people that had Diaries and I
remember having African friendly had all
this suitcase for the new clothes and
presents hair and jewelry there and I'm
like what are you doing I have to show
the family that I can support her yes
and it's like a whole ceremony but like
showing them what you can give showing
the family and that's what I mean
nowadays it's too easier for people to
go and get married they have to show the
family that they can look after that the
problem is the women nowadays aren't
worth it like why would I do all that
when she's out here in the street
why would a guy do that for a 31 year
old wife because I I've experienced this
recently and you know obviously I don't
have these traditional views right so
you know some of these guys are out here
counting body counts for me it's more
like in the way they act like I I messed
around with like an older woman like a
few months ago 42 only ever been with
one guy you know like and I can just
when I'm around her it's just like she's
from a different age there was no no
she's you know she's gorgeous so I'm not
running but she's from a different age
like just the way she behaves The Way
She carries herself the way she talks
very soft very pleasant not too
opinionated it's just like it's just
like that she's like a real woman
I realized that being with her I was
like yo there's no one in my generation
that can like being around someone like
that I was like you know what I'm a
bachelor I'm probably gonna be a
bachelor fight next five six seconds but
hanging out with her I was like yo I
actually get why people will like get
married
why was she on her own why is she 42 in
single fussy it's not your business I'm
not gonna I'm not gonna be saying that
okay I always say that's their story be
like there's modern modern you know
problems have modern solutions but
there's a lot of stuff going on here in
London but still I'm not gonna lie um
do you want children uh ideally yeah oh
what shame what's stopping you what are
you saying ideally
that's a bunch of things put me in the
right person the reason I was asking
because that woman sound like she's
captured a bit of him but she's old you
know what I mean it's like actually no
children no one can capture maybe but I
think I think I was close I always tell
her like if you were like 25 20 years
younger that's why I asked about
yourself
because you sounded like if she could
breed and be healthy or whatever I'm not
I'm not missing out
yeah I was just like yeah yeah if you
were like 20 years younger yeah
I'll be getting some Factory job I'll be
like
did you have something you want to just
add
I forgot okay now you said you're not
gonna lie oh yeah yeah I ain't going
like um don't lie I'm scared to get
married why because um The Generation
Now compared to back in the days I'm
talking before we were born it was
different like as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible